[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we're one
so do you like Game of Thrones meets a
catch I know I've heard it fun what show
do you like right now I just finished
two seasons of marvelous mrs. Mazal that
everyone's been bugging oh is it really
good I watched it worse two or three
episodes over and over because I'm like
I can't get into no so it's the same
thing it took about eight episodes work
I was like what is the big deal about
this show why is everywhere you know
what's really award no yeah I don't want
so many awards and then after the eighth
episode all the pay off happened and
then second season you're hooked because
all the characters have really good like
depth and arcs like you are invested in
every single character which a little
like just about her marvelous marvelous
mrs. Mazal is it on Netflix it is on
know prime is on Amazon probably oh
you're right you're right yeah QC and I
watched oh you have I don't even know
how far we got into it but then like
hurt like the main character kind of got
overwhelming for me where I'm like yeah
it's kind of annoying
I can't yeah and she talks she's really
really fast and I'm just like what she
gets better nice tits
she's a fantastic body like her body is
like the perfect shape I just can't stop
staring at her boobs are so many
different outfits I love this outfit me
too
like girls can like for us appreciate
another girl's beauty
almost unheard or sexually yeah and but
still be heterosexual cuz I don't think
a guy a guy could look at and do this
blood levels Jack and that's right and
yeah I don't feel like I need to keep
watching that yeah how influenced
influencers happen because after
watching I noticed I slowly started
dressing more like her or like doing my
makeup or hair like her more of those
ties in my hair
I didn't even notice I was yeah I didn't
even notice I was doing that but I
started putting on more lipstick instead
of lipgloss like it was it was weird
that I think that's how influence works
cuz I was like she's so pretty and her
body is so like happening to guys too
because then they'll be like oh that
guys wearing that jacket I want that to
look strong see if you saw Game of
Thrones there's a lot of women you could
appreciate like for example seeing them
all naked I can't buy any other clothes
missandei oh dude though she's still
[ __ ] fine oh yeah oh she's so [ __ ]
bad she's my favorite person ever did
[ __ ] your lover who cares
she's right hand girl holiness she is
probably one of the prettiest girls I've
ever seen them you know she's never got
some dick to so uh yeah she never got so
frustrated yeah yeah
he just will own that episode he ate her
out though oh yeah I got it work that's
a good man is like you know that dude is
actually do things great were great worm
is in real life he's a he's like a
really famous musician so interesting
that Podrick sing but not him I don't
have anything left to say go on some
great titties notice what I'm saying on
Game of Thrones she didn't make the
comment the red which her tits are nice
too but like when she becomes a
grandma's oh that made me throw up a
little bit a little bit a little bit we
just can't seem to not talk about it I
know I sorry wait so do you guys watch
any other shows wait the good doctor
I watched the Grell Academy I [ __ ]
love a brother Academy I gotta watch
that again I watched the first episode
or we did and we couldn't get into it so
maybe without a traumatic is it about it
that it turned you off it was so cheesy
in the beginning I agree oh I wasn't
digging it either but then the more I
watched it I'm like I could are you're
too nice a very revolutionary yeah
because it's not your typical superhero
type show it's it seemed pretty damn
superhero I mean pretty typical for
shows that I like or dislike now I don't
even have a reason for it it's just
sighs why do you dislike it I don't like
it binging so many shows because every
time I finish there's I like need to
find a new show and then I finished that
really fast to give me all that time
game Athos was the only one I cannot go
through I can't get through it
and no but it's like when I sit down on
my quota I want to watch it's never like
oh I'm dying to watch that really boy
like get in charge Ozarks no soul of
Ozark I just like first five minutes I'm
like this is boring
boy that's it you know some [ __ ] about
to happen the first five minutes
flooring for me yeah maybe whose ass I
always have to ask someone why they
don't like it or what turned them off
because I want to see what they see
mm-hmm I didn't like the mood like the
tone that they say it was like I mean
not to debate them or anything just it
just to understand what is it that makes
I don't like cheesy acting like that's
exactly what it is for me if the acting
is bad I can't watch that's why a breath
umbrella can't have been so good I see
that's what's what's interesting is
because you both don't like cheesy
acting but the way you see cheesing
acting at different that's what I'm
saying that's why saying it doesn't
matter no that's why it's interesting
and then he comes back what are you here
I'm like I'll shut the [ __ ] up like I
said with the night and then there's a
really buff no one likes the buff guy
either so those two characters nobody
really likes them that's all I needed
and I was like these guys are [ __ ]
obnoxious yeah
don't pay the to them the other two that
mean any fiends after like I couldn't
you agreed then they're cheesy I didn't
like those two I didn't like Robert
Sheehan acting either cuz he's plays the
same person Robert Sheehan which he's
the one that um the drug addict brother
oh wait the same oh he wasn't knowing -
I didn't like him at first and then he
became my favorite character he's really
good he's one of the best characters I
agree
but now you guys see where I'm coming
sir it then that's I guess the state
like he wanted to know what stopped you
and I that makes sense yeah but I'm
telling you everything is so good and
the writing is so good it's like you for
Game of Thrones like for me I like
timepieces I like stuff like that I like
fighting I like that right so any little
any little thing I can get past it
Yeah right because I already like that
where I say so superhero stuff it's not
my forte like I don't really like it
like I don't love steal your stuff but
but but
so I already go into with that so now I
think subconsciously I'm looking for any
little thing where i'm like i knows
like it okay so the tone reminds me of
the marvelous mrs. Mazal where it's kind
of cartoony and like a little bit
heightened but still believable hmm you
know and so maybe you got thrown off
because it is kind of cartoony like in
that sense that it's like comic book II
but it's it becomes more believable and
like you get investable arcs are really
[ __ ] good yeah the arcs are really
good so looks like back to my point it's
just people just like what they like
exactly the reason why you don't like it
is also the reason why she likes it but
you guys are still you I'm saying yeah
yeah when I try to explain like show
them why I like I just leave it like
this I like I like it because I can the
reasons why you like it are probably the
reasons why I like film values don't see
what you say so it's such a like I'm
trying to you just want to know that you
have shitty tastes and I have better
taste sometimes we just [ __ ] with things
and we just fun with it because we [ __ ]
with it aren't so good is so interpreted
I love bad quality [ __ ] because it's bad
quality yeah sometimes it's fun because
it's so it's campy instead and then also
we there's another layer added to what
you're saying because we're all friends
we we all assume that we should all and
yeah like the same thing together so we
can talk about it and bought on it more
and then when we don't we're like why I
thought we were you know it's funny
though because people will accept this
when it comes to food but when it comes
to content watching TV and things like
that it becomes a lot more torture
because it comes back to like people
like me like shows like this so you're
people like me you should like the shows
that are [ __ ] no no one's gonna connect
with the [ __ ] I enjoy you like Game of
Thrones that's what I watch like what
real [ __ ] that I enjoy triose homeless
homeless people playing piano okay
nevermind you know what i binge real
estate videos but specifically notice
barbar likes that poor yep but
specifically man the non-porn version
ranch ranch walkthroughs i'll watch any
real estate videos as long as it's set
up there's like a John Wayne kind of guy
with the low voice that's narrating the
whole thing and in there's like another
one that's kind of like um
Samuel NASA male attraction Morgan
Freeman and
very different inundate these describe
the property and there's like a [ __ ]
drone going through like all 200 acres
and I've been binge watching those
videos
do you like the home shows then like
they're like extraordinary homes Steve
and I are so into extraordinary it was
our said we've got there was another
season but then there was only three
episodes or four episodes I was like
bummed out yeah I like the fixing oh we
like those tears let me seen the Airbnb
ones yeah that was a dope one with the
there's like a gay guy and then the girl
that wouldn't ya so they're they're
people that rent out their homes to
Airbnb yes then the show is they go in
and then they like fix it up better so
that it's like you're more likely to
have it oh that's cool it's really cool
that's cool too if you want to like buy
investment property and like I know what
is involved in that
that's so intimidating to me like
investment property cuz I'm just like
people had like this foresight of like
this dumpy ass Shack is gonna look like
this modern and dope thing and I'm like
that's awesome I think if you die I
don't I don't worry about that I worry
about the type of people that will stay
there
and those videos where you can't kick
them out have you seen those people have
trouble kicking out the Airbnb people
and they just don't know because like
there's some like sort of laws yeah yeah
it's really [ __ ] up yeah yeah that's
the [ __ ] that I that scares me I'm like
[ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] put my heart and
soul to this project I'm gonna make a
dope yeah and someone's gonna [ __ ]
party and puke all over it yeah it's
like I'm gonna start a business but then
not even provide that business for
everyone I'm just gonna fix [ __ ] up and
leave it there that's why taxi cabs get
mad and when you throw up in their car
that makes up in their car yeah but I
was drugged I talked about it before you
did I was drugged at a club and then my
luckily my cousins were there to like
take me and I was already trying to
throw it up in the bathroom because I
knew I was drunk because I only drank
half a drink and I couldn't walk and I
could barely see and yeah
I just think you're hurting it for the
first time yeah it's at all and then she
told us that suppose I don't remember
that you sitting in that seat I think I
didn't hear the story maybe I was
hosting no no okay multiple times
I remember you're on the verge of
getting raped
that's very true that's like your thing
yeah that's why they call me the miracle
man miracle miracle is you always almost
get kidnapped that's like your [ __ ]
instead of in too deep she's like just
makes me just missed it
yeah that's her the just miss ditch is
the person that walks in the cards alone
mr. Bhagu my way through life David
walks into parked cars Hey David's
walking in the open prairie and a plane
goes what what happens is after I got
hit by play somehow I don't have my
limbs he's still alive yes unluckiest
man ever oh for sure so anything more to
that story
oh well basically when I knew I was
drugged my cousins were just surrounding
me and like what's the bathroom tried to
throw it up like someone yeah yeah so we
had bottle service but our table was in
the middle of the club basically and it
was like a booth with a ledge all the
way around and so everyone was setting
their drinks on that ledge but people
were walking by that ledge some guy was
like putting [ __ ] yeah and I think a
lot of the girls like I don't know we're
more conscious of the drinks I never
went out you don't do this [ __ ] yeah the
hand over the top out and so I was only
going by to stop by I'm not a girl and I
even noticed [ __ ] but I was just going
by to say hi really quick and then I was
gonna leave because I lived like right
down the street
but you always carry your drink with you
well I didn't know I was 21 and I was
very dumb and I did it aids don't
include the age I was 60
but I was at a club just say you were 16
you should be club leader 15 I had a
think I was really cool yeah yeah yeah
that's she didn't know any better yeah
that's crazy I really don't remember
this why cuz you were right there I
don't remember it the last time you said
you didn't remember yeah I wonder if
there's ever been like a really ugly
girl where you know parents are advising
them is like hey make sure you take your
drinks and then you have that one ugly
daughter she goes I always cover my
drinks and the dad goes you don't you
don't worry about that she's got the
club like she's like trying to she's
like Jack the kiss it's just like please
please I'm gonna go talk to my friends
real quick and i'ma leave my drink here
huh you're always nice my friend she was
in Vegas and then you know how like your
friends try to like protect you from
going out and being like a hoe and stuff
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] blockers I wanted some
dick that night oh there's some weird
friends no no shoot they were like I got
a club in Vegas with a group of girls at
Enya if your girl fight okay and then
yeah she wanted to go out with this guy
she had a connection with but she was
like the ugly one other group then she
barely gets any dick so she finally had
her opportunity but all her homegirls
like no you don't want to do this yeah I
miss come so I had this group this
girlfriend that we're not really friends
anymore [ __ ] you yeah honestly like she
knows but we used to go to Vegas and it
would always be like here like girls
trip like it's a girls trip right no
boyfriends no nothing
and when Steve and I first started
dating I wanted to go to Vegas with him
so bad but this girl's trip came up and
I'm like I'm sorry I have to go with
these girls before you and that sucks
because I was like man I really wanted
to go with him first and so I was trying
not to hype it up and I'm like sorry no
boyfriend so it was just it was ice and
the whole time all she wanted to do was
go out and find dudes and she was
married with a kid and she was they were
about to have their second like when she
got back from that show there was like
let's go all this cheating trip you guys
could do my
and then she yelled at me at a casino
cuz she thought I was trying to steal
her man I'm like I don't even want to
talk to guys I want my boyfriend here
you guys were just basically used so
she's yeah so she could be like oh honey
I'm gonna do this all girls trip see
yeah yeah you didn't want the guy so
should we go get some dick yeah and then
she was canoodling with him up at the
pool I was cuddling me she was like
couldn't look cuddly probably like
kissing and stuff whatever they were
doing she's really the definition of
what stays and babies in the hotel and
her phone kept ringing and it was her
husband like texting pictures with the
kid and stuff and being like she misses
you mommy it was like oh my god and then
what a car but yeah their friend left
the day early cuz I was like I don't
want to be here that's very just us
three and I was supposed to be a girls
trip and stuff and then with the other
girl a part of this thing - she's like
yeah let's [ __ ] cheap best no now
what you two were kind of bamboozled it
we all had boyfriends or she had the
girl had a husband and then me and I
don't want any single girls there cuz
then exactly that's true it's like if I
was like hey we're supposed to go to the
club and pretend like we're single so
then we get this ego boost and then we
go home and [ __ ] our boyfriends that's
very different it is that's like if I
had my mind set on that and then here's
like my homegirls like [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of other dudes and cheating and I'm
accomplice oh yeah you feel dirty mm-hmm
I hated it I don't like flirting with
you if I knew the guy way before I knew
the girl that came into his life right
and I found out - the guy was cheating
on her I'd be like cuz I don't I'm not
really a mostly investment to her right
right because he's still my friend yeah
you're still that new person so if I saw
that and he was like yeah I'm [ __ ]
brothers I'm like yes you are I'm a
friend like that well we didn't like his
significant other so we were just like
what it is we'll see that's the thing is
that we were friends with them as a
couple
we had so many game nights together and
like he was a really good guy you know
anything about this about her so okay -
it's nothing but it came as a surprise
cuz you didn't know this about her yeah
because if she was like telling you like
custom pick all this [ __ ] come on bro
girls trip I never would have gone maybe
she thought girls trip was like
everybody gonna get some dick yeah maybe
it was like normal damn what did you
think when I invited you on our cross
trip by like here we call a pen I'm
gonna get some dick I'm ready this time
I've been married quite the opposite
happen yeah I thought that was a myth I
thought it was a myth that people go to
Vegas and then just [ __ ] around yeah
what do you mean that's a myth that
sounds very real so innocent because you
could do anything in Vegas I thought you
go there when you're single and you [ __ ]
around oh I see well that's how it
should be I don't think you go there to
[ __ ] oh wait I know you cheat on your
wife
so we'll see about that swinger couple
that we're celebrating their 15th year
anniversary I had no idea parties like
that we saw that old man that Warren
Buffett dude with the high-class hooker
yeah
the Warren Buffett guy was gay with this
we were getting the car in the valley
wait were you there I don't think I was
no wasn't there that's what he took your
girl picture without me she wasn't with
us
it was Gina jazz booty why weren't you
there I thought we were gonna waiting
for the van she burped
we were trying to find you guys and then
I even texted the group like hey we're
in the Oberlin if anyone wants to share
an uber and also no response they were
busy taking pictures without me any but
we photoshopped you in I like that in
our vlog now look Missy Photoshop did
you feel left out yeah I like feeling
with it I told you I was like I woke up
this morning feeling like this anxiety
like I don't even know cuz you missed
out on the picture the other day no no
this was before and I was like I got
woke up in like a really anxiety mood
because like for some reason sometimes I
think everyone hates me and I told Gio
that and then after that they took the
picture without me whoa whoa whoa that
that's really [ __ ] up it literally
wasn't after that it was right after so
it was before the show I told you this
we go to the show right after the show
they all take pictures well you think
it's gonna happen Nicki they're like no
we shouldn't take the picture and make
this a moment last forever because
Nikki's gonna you know how many girls
there are no but we did we were like
where's Nicki
there was no titushki I would have come
died from a trip you and I showed you
the told us not wait for Nicki City too
long in my head that's how it went in my
head everyone's like that's so funny
that sucks
damn that that's a nightmare but I just
laughed because it was because of the
irony of it all oh no reason
did you see on Instagram another photo
but do you know what's missing out of
them yeah then there was always one girl
man you didn't give a [ __ ] you did I
turn without Tina was it she already got
one that's my cue already better by that
Joe he's got one plus I was the one that
was like let's not take a girl photo
without Geo because last year geo wasn't
in the girl photo cuz she had to go up
because Bart was sick Bart's always say
oh he's sick in Vegas
what was he see class he wasn't feeling
good cuz he drank oh that's right that's
why you guys missed a strip clubs yeah
[ __ ] everyone's that one was pretty
fun honestly I got desensitized to boobs
maybe that's why I don't like Game of
Thrones that much because like I got so
desensitized you're bringing it back
[ __ ] matter
[Music]
[Music]